No, you started your Tuesday at 2pm
(bouncy noise)
You know when you're drinking because you're stressed, and then you get drunk, by surprise. Yeah, that happened last night.
(laughs)
Hi, my name is Grace Helbig and you don't know, now you know. Your life is different now.
Hey, alright. I woke up so hungover today, and I couldn't think of a video idea
so I thought we'd just do this. Thought I would just sit down today
and show you guys how I do my makeup on days when I'm wildly hungover to trick others into thinking I'm not.
So the first thing I normally do is spend hours in bed in a cloud of my own regret-
I spared you. Don't worry. I did that already off-camera. Now we're gonna shower our hair. This is what a role model looks like.
This morning I found out that I had a scab on my scalp
and I have no idea where that's from. Life should be about constant self-discovery.
Okay, now let's fix the face.
Most times I wash my face, but f*ck it. I'm just taking some toner and
slapping it on the skin that's saying "please just take care of me".
Yum, yum, yum. Skin get all of that out.
Ugh. Catch me. Why you gotta be so rude? Don't you know I'm garbage, too? (laughs)
I know you guys are probably sick of how many makeup videos there have been lately, and
I'm not a doctor. I can't heal your sickness. I'm sorry.
Then I take this. Ooh, product placement!
This is called Enlite Super Face Wake Up Eyes Cooling Eye Invigorator.
This came free in a swag bag from an event. Do I think it's great?
I don't know, but I have it. Okay, that goes under our eyes.
(exhales)
My Winter 2017 look is "Haggard".
And I use this! This was in my favorites video.
It's Evan Healy Lemon Thyme Facial Tonic
and I just spray it on my face and say "erase the mistakes"
and it stings so it feels kind of like a punishment for the choices I've made.
Then we do this, because we're our biggest fan, ha ha
Did I wash my hands before doing this? Nope.
Okay, what's next?
A check on our Amazon Prime Now order.
The other thing I did before this was make myself macaroni and cheese and eat 3/4ths of a box.
I earned it!
Absolutely not.
So now let's start painting our mask on our face so we can prank everyone.
Make them think that we didn't shower and vodka last night, not at all.
I just got you and you're so scummy already. Very on-brand.
I've been using this Garnier BB Cream 5-in-1 Miracle Skin Perfector.
She could use a miracle today, that's what she could use.
I use this kind of as a base, and then I put regular foundation on top.
Mmm, just slap it on there. We are capable. We are
not good at coming up with mantra songs. Our charm is in our sloppy, floppy, human Muppetness
we say to ourself, over and over.
Now I put foundation on. I found this Revlon Youth FX Fill + Blur Foundation. Oh!
But I didn't pick the right color for me, as per usual
so I just kind of mix it with another foundation I have.
Sure. Just bop it on there.
Okay.
Our poor decision-making has been reduced by a fair amount, already.
Let's get the under-eye-
-s better. Let's turn these under-eye bags into under-eye Jags-
-uars, Jaguars. Something people want.
Were you gonna use this NYX Dark Circle Conc-
Talking is hard.
NYX Dark Circle Concealer, bam!
And we're just gonna pile it on there.
I don't know I just kinda blend it with the beauty blender, and then "whoa"!
Look who's gonna make people think she actually got REM sleep last night.
(hehehehe)
Now let's
What do we do? A general life question, really.
Ah, let's work on eyebrows!
I just got this Soap and Glory thing, for eyebrows.
It's called Archery 2-in-1 Brow, and I like him very much.
It's got a little spoolie with like brow gel on one side and then a pencil on the other and what I do-
Put the gel on first, then I put the brows stuff on, then I put more gel on.
That's excessive and probably completely unnecessary, but it's just what I do - excessive and unnecessary.
That's also a very good idea for it, the name of a perfume.
Oh, my Prime Now might be coming soon.
Okay, let that set a second.
Then I use the pencil and I go over it, and I make them look like eyebrows.
I forgot about talking and trying to entertain at the same time.
Oh, look who's curious and coy and kind of flirty and creepy.
Me! What's next is your battery is low, so let's change that. What's symbolism, ha ha?
Okay, we're gonna do maybe kind of an overcompensating look because
we not only want to trick others we want to trick ourselves into thinking
We're put together. Everything's on track, the way it should be
and we can do anything we put our minds to, like drink ourselves into the present day hangover.
I'm gonna use the same Kylie eye shadow palette that I used in my sexy fall makeup thing. There's been so many makeup videos.
Sorry, I'm in an era of liking makeup for half a second. I'm gonna tone it down a little bit.
It's not gonna be so heavy-handed
so I'm going to take this one - very descriptive - and put it under my eyebrow bone
and then in the tear duct so people think "whoa, she's bright-eyed and bushy-tailed".. not
Sh*t face and wobbly. (laugh)
Then I take the next one, the shimmery
and I put that one all over the eyelid. Just smearing it all over there.
Then we'll take maybe these two browns, mix 'em a little bit and put them in the crease. Oohoo.
Okay. Then we just blend it 'til it looks like one of those Instagram makeup artists did their own makeup
with their non-dominant hand. Fun.
Talking, talking, talking.
Alright! That's a thing! Fine enough. Fine is the goal.
Maybe we'll do some liquid liner?
Why not? This is NYX Epic Ink Liner. I love this liquid liner, it rules, so we're gonna use it. Talk amongst yourselves.
I'll give you a topic. Each one of you should try and get two people to subscribe to my YouTube channel because it's fun!
Oh boy. Alright, whoa? She's awake. This is always a gamble to see if they look like they're related. Yeah again fine
Mmm? Again, fine, we'll take it. Alright.
Now we do eyelashes.
Hold on. We're really playing Trixie's today.
I've got some individual lashes, but sets of three
that I'm gonna put on some fake lashes because we're going for it.
First I wanna put a quick layer of mascara on. This is The Falsies' Volum' Express.
False feels appropriate.
This is definitely very old and probably shouldn't be being put on my eyelashes because of bacteria
but we ourselves are a petri dish of Lord knows what.
I'm pretty bad at doing this so this is likely just another bad decision but mm
We're gonna push our luck.
Oh, no. No, no. Okay.
Ugh, a bad idea.
Oh God. Oh God. Oh God. Bad. Bad. Oh sh-
Okay, ooh, ha. Then why are we doing this?
Try the other side. (exhales) No one's stressed out, everyone's having fun!
Let the fun boys get in there and play with other lashes, motherf-
Good enough, good enough, good enough.
My Amazon Prime Now is gonna be here in a second.
Ha ha, Prime Now delivery received
and he had no idea I was hungover.
Well, I'm not done yet, so maybe he had a little bit of an idea.
The struggle saga is over, they're on.
We're gonna put a little bit more mascara on just to blend them in. I don't know if that's really necessary
but people do it. I'm using this other mascara that I think is less bacteria filled
Oh, it's Covergirl's Total Tease by the way for anyone that gives a f*ck.
We'll do our bottom lashes too, 'cause
everyone gets touched by products today.
Ooh, Touch My Products, it's a great makeup base soap opera name.
Now put some bronzer on! I use this Bronx Colors bronzing face powder, ooh!
And I like it so much, I broke the lid off of it. I'm a monster!
Okay, bronzer.
We've been bronzed. We've been kissed with consent by the Sun.
Blush! Let's put blush on.
I'm using Goulue from NARS. It's also in my last favorites video.
And it makes me feel like a giant when I hold it.
Oh, so coy!
Then let's put some setting powder on. I have this NYX HD Finishing Powder. Oh, so scummy and dirty.
I like to sometimes just take my beauty blender
and put it in and put the powder on.
Okay, now all we need is a lip color!
Look, can you see? This is Clinique Chubby Stick - Heaping Hazelnut.
Heaping Hazelnut? More like, weeping Helbig is nuts.
There we go. We're done!
This is my everyday "let's hide the mistakes away" hangover makeup look
Who's this girl? Not full of regret.
That's what- You got pranked!
I would trust this person to make good choices.
There you go, guys! That's this video. If you liked it, give it a thumbs up. Leave a comment down below
What's your go-to hangover routine?
Make sure you subscribe to this YouTube channel. Click that button if you haven't already and hit that Bell notification
so you know when I post videos because I'm trying to post Monday through Friday
but the time of day in which the posting happens varies, so get notified.
I don't know.
You can bring a horse to water, but you can't teach it to drink, 'cause this horse already knows how to f*cking drink! Something like that, right?